after two weeks of denying that anything
said in the impeachment hearings was
true Donald Trump went on Fox News and
he admitted to the entire thing for the
first time publicly linking the supposed
of corruption investigations that he
wanted Ukraine to do through the
military aid this is the first time it's
happened publicly you can't write a more
ridiculous storyline if this were a
screenplay it would be rejected
immediately because it's too
over-the-top it's not believable and yet
it's the reality that we live in so let
me explain to you what took place Donald
Trump on Friday promoted an appearance
on Fox & Friends
after smearing impeachment witnesses
after denying that anything
inappropriate happened saying quote I
will be interviewed on Fox & Friends
this morning at 8:00 a.m. I know that
there's not much to talk about but we
will try to keep the conversation going
enjoy and indeed it was an interesting
conversation because in this interview
Donald Trump admitted to the entire
thing
not on purpose I don't think he even
realizes that he admitted to the entire
thing I don't know that the average Fox
News viewer realizes that Trump admitted
to the entire thing that he spent the
two weeks of impeachment hearings
denying in this clip he admits that he
asked on the phone call for Ukraine to
investigate Biden and he says I did ask
them and why should we give them
hundreds of millions of dollars linking
the investigation request to the
hundreds of millions of dollars in aid
for the first time publicly and I still
want to see that server you know the FBI
has never gotten that server that's a
big part of this whole thing why did
they give it to a Ukrainian company
where are you sure they did that are you
sure they Dave it to Ukraine well that's
what the word is and that's what I asked
actually in my phone call of you know I
mean I asked it very point-blank because
we're looking for corruption this
tremendous corruption we're looking for
why should we be giving hundreds of
millions of dollars to countries when
there's this kind of corruption man if
you look at my call I said you know
corruption I think he said it to me he's
looking he got elected on the basis of
corruption
without realizing it admits that that is
exactly what he did we're looking for
corruption we asked them to do it and
why should we give them the money
implying of course if they don't want to
help look for corruption meaning chase
down some absurd conspiracy theory and
then use it to smear Joe Biden why would
we give them money
this went completely over the heads of
so many people that were watching this
but this is Trump blurting out that the
thing that he's been denying for weeks
is absolutely true
here's another rambling moment from the
interview where Trump said I always want
corruption it was a weird moment no you
were ambassador to the United to the EU
mister Sundlun in his opening statement
said that there was quid pro quo there
was quid pro quo he said because you
wanted an investigation into corruption
in exchange for a visit to the White
House or something like that
yeah well that's total nonsense I do
want always corruption I say that to
anybody why should we give money to a
country that's known corrupt it's a very
corrupt country I mean I love the people
in Ukraine I know Ukrainian people
they're great people but it's known as
being the third most corrupt country in
the world ok so I mean I guess it seems
pretty clear that Trump is not saying
what he meant to say there is it a
Freudian slip who knows but once again
bringing up why should we give the money
unless they do what we say unless they
do what we ask them to do which is
investigate Joe Biden he is admitting to
the whole thing yet again without even
realizing it he's not admitting to it in
the way that we might imagine would
happen but this is Trump publicly
linking these vague corruption concerns
which are of course code for investigate
Joe and hunter Biden linking that to the
hundreds of millions of dollars in
military aid the other thing that's not
being mentioned enough is if Trump is
insisting that Ukraine is rife with
corruption I I want to say this again if
Trump believes Ukraine is just
corruption Laden why would you insist on
Ukraine invest
corruption why would you trust someone
so corrupt to investigate corruption for
you it doesn't make any sense then
there's one other really funny moment
from this interview when Trump did that
CrowdStrike server conspiracy theory
thing even Fox News host Steve Doocy had
to say are you sure about that
and if you are watching you will notice
that the look on Ainsley Earhardt face
it never moves during this entire
interview Brian Kilmeade starts doing
his sort of confused face and Steve
Doocy feels compelled to because he
knows that what Trump is saying is bogus
he feels compelled to say are you sure
about that take a look have the server
right from the DNC Democratic National
Committee who has the cirno the FBI
wanted and they told him get out of here
you're not kidding we're not giving it
to you
they gave the server to CrowdStrike or
whatever it's called which is a country
which is a company owned by a very
wealthy Ukranian and I still want to see
that server you know the FBI has never
gotten that server that's a big part of
this whole thing why did they give it to
a Ukrainian company where are you sure
they did that are you sure they gave it
to Ukraine well that's what the word is
and that's what I asked actually and my
phone call of you know I mean I asked it
very point-blank because we're looking
for corruption Brian Kilmeade I think is
smarter than the other two and he
realizes with that that you can tell
this is not a good thing for Donald
Trump to be saying this entire Fiasco
went on for 50 minutes in a bizarre
rambling interview filled with
self-incrimination filled with lies but
understand Trump believes it's smart for
him to testify on his own behalf that's
why last week when Donald Trump said I
might be interesting and interested in
testifying in this impeachment hearing I
told you his lawyers will do everything
possible so that he doesn't because just
like in this interview he will
self-incriminate and he doesn't even
realize it he believes that he can talk
his way out of anything and come away
convincing everybody in the room to go
over to his point of view and case in
point Trump did this interview on Fox
News and did not even realize that he
admitted for the first time publicly
that indeed the invest
negations he wanted ukraine to do were
indeed linked to the hundreds of
millions of dollars in aid people are
getting death threats against themselves
and their families for coming forward to
testify about this and Trump just blurts
it out on live television and of course
otherwise completely incoherent
throughout the interview if I mean this
is an aside it's an aside scandal if
Barack Obama had ever done one
incoherently rambling word salad
interview like this Republicans would
have immediately called for Barack
Obama's removal under the 25th amendment
to the Constitution Trump does it almost
every time he speaks publicly and not
only do they stand behind him
they are almost smitten with his public
persona and his public presence it is
something else and I don't know when and
how we are going to come out of it I've
suggested some of the ways and I've
talked about the uphill battle that it
will be but this is going to be a big
big recovery process for the United
States if we are ever to undertake it
and complete it and I hope that we do I
hope that we do make sure you're
following the david pakman show on
instagram at david pakman show while
you're there follow me at David Pakman
we'll take a quick break and be back
with much more one of today's sponsors
is privacy calm slash Pakman this is a
free service that I've actually been
using myself for a while now and I love
it you just take a few seconds to link
your debit card or bank account to
privacy calms mobile app or browser
extension for Firefox and Chrome and
what that does is allow you to instantly
create virtual credit cards that are
linked to your bank account so that
you're not actually putting your real
debit card number on the Internet and
you use these virtual credit card
numbers to buy things online and with
one click of a button you have the
ability to create multiple virtual cards
delete cards freeze and unfreeze cards
you can put a limit on a card so a
company won't be able to charge you more
than you actually want them to and it
protects you from being hacked it
protects you from companies being hacked
which we've been talking about for a
while on the probe
and it's perfect for signing up for free
trial somewhere if you don't want your
real credit card number to be exposed
and on file and their app and browser
extension let you autofill the virtual
credit card number into the credit card
field when you're buying things online
there are a ton of different advantages
to shopping and paying bills with a
system like this everything is totally
secure and encrypted and in some
situations you can earn 5% cash back on
your purchases it's all completely free
all you have to do is click the link
under this video to get started and for
a limited time everybody in our audience
who signs up gets $5.00 towards your
first purchase when you sign up using
that link below